there's a bunch of questions around the
execution of how to do good that maybe
we should address sherry is writing
about uh she's thinking about donating a
portion of her profits to helping donate
books to children in hospitals mahal
Ville is asking does donating blood
count being a blood donor and so maybe
just a dress in a different ways that
you can give back different different
strategies different tactics different
execution that people can feel like
they're making a contribution yeah I
think money time expertise there's loads
of different ways and again with this
you know I'd say always start small just
take baby steps just take the first step
with anything you know if you're going
to sell overseas open up a german
website whatever always take you know
don't try and rule the world in a
afternoon go take baby steps move before
you can run so you know simple thing
dependent ask yourself what do you
really care about and it's
entrepreneur's you know why did you
start business in the first place
because you saw a gap in the market
something really annoyed you about our
product that you will have something
that really fires you up and the second
thing is help me going access to it
because cuz and again great thing about
social media is there's so much out
there that you can connect your passion
with charity that needs help the all
these charities will need help and your
new unique individuals you've got
tremendous expertise you could give you
know half their month you give them a
couple of hours you could do a skype
call with them there's loads of
different ways there are relevant to
what are their needs it's almost like
what we talked about another plant go in
this case you've always got to go where
the audiences and then the second thing
is what is their needs what do they
think that they're stopping them and
then as you get to know you'll find that
there will be other thing so they
haven't even thought about where your
expertise can help and it's not always
money you know monies to Evan point
money money actually doesn't always
solve the problem
my pesantren that it's I think the same
ethos we have like bootstrap stuff is
awesome saying we don't want charities
that were involved in wasting money and
you know stop spending stupid money sort
of philosophy and treat the charity's
money even more as if it's your own
money and make sure every Lee every
dollar really makes a difference to the
bottom of people are certain so I think
there's a range of things but what our
advocate is it starts more to start I'm
just take you know maybe a couple of
hours a month and then find out one of
the needs and then start filling those
needs and I think you'll find a rich
relationship where you can make a
massive difference to something you
really are passionately kind of lynn is
remanence Steven what a touching
wonderful story thank you for sharing I
get another one leap from the heart and
the head will follow Thank You Steven so
that I mean to summarize I loved how you
brought that together where it's money
time and expertise and we've talked
about a lot of different kinds of
strategies we've talked about donating a
portion of your salary and maybe the
government has some program to match it
Steven talked about mentoring and going
to junior achievement and giving back to
the local charities their mentoring
people who have gone through the
criminal record or they're in
impoverished neighborhoods and trying to
help them get back on their feet I think
donating blood counts like it's a way to
get back right maybe doesn't fall into
our three categories he was like a
fourth money great time expertise and
and I don't know body parts or something
there but but like it's a way to get
even if you have 0 money zero knowledge
02 teens you can still find a way to get
back by donating blood or volunteering
out of food bank let Steven did with
this team there's always a way to do
something and I think I think it's an
important point because a lot of people
watching or try to think of how they
might get back me feel like well I don't
have money to start a foundation like I
love what's H is doing but I'm nowhere
near that I'm just trying to pay my
bills and I'm put you know make sure my
internet stays on and feed my family but
just threw a
little bit of time by mentoring somebody
or giving back to some local thing
happening in your area or you know being
a collar for an anti-bullying campaign
or whatever it is there's always a way
that you can get back to something that
touches your heart there's so many
causes that that are out there that need
talented dedicated people who will take
all the time you have like if you have
ten hours a month they'll take it if you
have one hour month they'll take it
right there's always waited to give back
and I think giving back also makes you
feel better in like Stephen said he
comes to the office next day with that
extra little hop in his step because he
feels good about the work that he's
doing so I love the advice that Stephen
gave about starting small and just
finding a way to do it